一级散户,据人杰的当冲策略,当冲,究竟能不能赚钱?
可以,但很难,没有策略,没有逻辑就去当冲,就只是赌博。
据人杰,17岁进入股市,只买得起当时一张不到一万的友达,
14年后已成为累计成交量达5000亿的重量级交易者。
他利用多年,培养逻辑与架构,建立一些当冲策略。
当冲记法一
观察海外期货
据人节的看盘画面
平常一定会放着日本、韩国、中国、美国各种指数
若其他国家的股市出现重大事件
尤其是大型利空
难道台湾股市能够逆势而行
非常强势吗
当冲记法二
观察加权指数
热门股
若是看一些新闻分析
经常都会看到一些标题
类似于加权指数要上2万点
但大多数都只是乱猜乱喊
加权指数一点都不神奇
就只是一条数学公式而已
以2024年1月31日为例
第一名台积电市值
约占大盘比重29%
当台积电强势时
再加上相关概念股影响加权指数的比例便会超过三成所以巨人结在分析整个大盘时首要之物就是分析台积电的状况
这样一来,加权指数的初步分析就会成型了
当冲击法三,观察海其重要数据
全世界投资人总是秉析以待美国公告的几个重要数据
包括联准会利率决议
美国非农就业人数变化
美国消费者物价指数
这些数据都有明确的公布时间点
等于是明确地预告
几点几分波动会来
于是我们可以借此衍生出台指期时间差策略
举例来说
如果小纳斯达克在数据公布的时间点
瞬间出现2%涨幅
台指期至少会跟着出现一半规模的波动
也因此有1%以上的涨幅空间
掌握这数秒的时间差
就是非常好的交易机会
若有人问
用什么方式来训练交易最有用
巨人结会给的答案
应该是检讨
他常说
如果你连赔一块钱的原因都找出来
十年之后
还是赚不了钱的机会
为乎其为
投资一定有风险
普票买卖有赚有赔
申购钱请祥月
巨人思维
MING PAO CANADA MING PAO TORONTO